watch this see that's a very good place
for you in the depths of health because
there's some reason
[Applause]
that there were no there were no wnds in
Iraq
and are dying she's not lying
one week
and then watch one more person's coming
one more person Pat that is brave I
respect he's been watched there he is
[Music]
you're what you're a sad old drunk
yes
aren't you supposed to be part of the
indictment tomorrow yes you're a warrant
Criminal by Death
Miss Pelosi you got some nerve is that
why you're here in Manhattan wow is that
why you're here because you're getting
indicted tomorrow you goddamn more
criminals
oh guys he's very very precise mind you
uh Rob Hillary's on stage too notice how
nobody said Hillary Hillary was
questioning her wasn't she that's the
only thing is it good because they
didn't want to get suicide Paul Krugman
no the thumbnail had uh Hillary on the
left I was like is there a difference
yeah no no who's in the left that's Paul
Krugman
I thought my bad I thought Hillary was
up there as well I didn't know it was
just them true but anyway Pat I I love
as a veteran too I love when there's
moments like this where people oh yeah
there's nobody else uh the thumbnail had
it it's just we need more people like
this oh standing up because mind you you
see this audience this look at look at
these these libtards he's standing up
yelling and they they won't even let you
say your peace because it's true it's
true all the Wars all the all the Iraq
and module I'm going back back to Bush
for all these anybody that got us into
these words are the accountability zero
accountability how is bush bush Rumsfeld
I mean Cheney uh none of them got in
trouble none of them got their their
held to the fire we went to war because
there was weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq we didn't find them so what'd they
do Pat they changed the name of the war
to what was it Iraqi enduring Freedom or
something and nobody ever pays the price
operation enduring freedom and yeah
because you just changed the name
because we're already there and we
couldn't find anything because they knew
it wasn't it's branding we'll make it
sound better yeah no of course but then
now and then now you have a an
ex-president who who hooked up with a
porn star if that's what you want to
call her and that that that person gets
arrested and and goes to jail like I
talk about me you're talking about no
I'm talking about Trump though okay I'm
not the remote but it's just it's just
those type of moments make me happy that
people have the balls to stand up and
yell at them which it ain't going to do
anything but I'm I'm a little confused
okay okay I'm just a little confused by
this because we can make a list of all
the wrong doings that Nancy Pelosi has
done okay granted I'm not here to defend
Nancy Pelosi at all but on my list of
things that I would be upset with Nancy
Pelosi about the Iraq war is not on the
top of the list because we this is after
what 2003 Afghanistan was a 102 and then
we went into Iraq in 03 okay Rob fact
check the [__] out of me right now I'm
sure that I don't think Nancy Pelosi
became speaker of the house until 2007
2008 right before Obama became elected
fact check well she was in politics
but she's not the person she's not the
tip of the spear what year Rob
uh 2007. okay all right so five years
after all this went down now you're
gonna come after her again I'm not
defending Pelosi yeah these people are
angry they're upset they want
accountability God bless them and they
deserve it but I just I don't it's not
adding up to me the war criminal thing
corrupt ridiculous absurd crazy nervous
Nancy drunk drunk all totally acceptable
yeah warmonger okay by the way I don't
even know about the nor nobody's proven
with Nordstrom too whether it was
Russians ukrainians America or us we
don't know us
again I'm not defending Nancy here I I
empathize with these people they're
upset about a whole host of [__] that's
going on in San Francisco California I'd
be out there
getting crazy too I just don't know if
this specific
um meltdown is actually that warranted I
think it shows that there's some
underlying tensions about her I think
that's the long and short of X I agree
with you it's like wait a minute what
are you actually talking about and you
could pick apart the actual things
they're saying but I think what it says
underneath there is that there's a lot
more dissatisfaction with Nancy Pelosi
than the media and her and her careful
branding spin but I agree with you what
are you talking about factually we can
break this down say number one you're
rude number one it's disrespectful other
citizens are coming here to hear
something
um and this and so we should actually
feel sorry for the Pelosi's because
getting hammered is is uh it's just a
problem for that and yeah Paul gets
hammered well different kind of
hammering but and then Nancy's getting
hammered you know so the poor Pelosi's
they're just dealing with the hammer
this year so why don't we just leave
them alone and Vinnie brings up a good
point if I mean listen if there's
anybody that this if you're angry about
this we're this direction this heat
should be headed it's the Bush
George W bush Dick Cheney Donald
Rumsfeld the list goes on yeah and
believe me those guys have heard it for
years uh we had uh Ari Fleischer here
yeah Ari Fleischer was the uh press
secretary for Bush during 9 11 yeah
Afghanistan Iraq and he even said listen
this is something that I have to wear
for the rest of my life when we said
they have weapons of mass destruction
and he had to take that out and I think
Ari Fleischer is a capable informed
smart dude and I even asked him about
that on the podcast Pat you remember
he's like yeah I got I have no response
we [__] up yeah but Adam I think cost
America trillions of dollars then the
Heller Burton strategic Revenue plan I
mean yeah yeah rock war the military
industrial Oklahoma here's my thing Adam
I'm not happy with just taking the L you
need to take his ass to jail because
they like hold on we're not talking
about uh who should go to jail everybody
that signed on and said we are going to
Iraq because they have this and we
killed over a million million women
children so we ruined that going there
from Iraq to Afghanistan to everything
started because of that from 9 11 to
that and no who who has gone through
jail for killing all those people
because that's like saying all right
guys we're gonna go and shoot up Tom's
house because Tom stole this from us and
we go there we shoot up town we shoot
the whole thing and then we're like oh
[__] Tom didn't steal it now what we
just get to make an Ella just walk away
[__] I think you bring up a good point
because I think whether it's what you're
saying right now whether that's that's
those angry protesters whether it's
going on what's happening in the banking
system right now people want
accountability 100 and the problem is
the people at the top very rarely are
held accountable whether it's Bush
whether it's freaking fouchy whoever it
is and I think a lot of the anger
especially from the right is like okay
so nobody's held accountable but Donald
Trump pays a [__] porn star some hush
money and now he's held accountable this
is [__] and I understand people's
frustration because so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]